I'm in the English countryside near Canterbury,
and this is a level crossing.
Nothing too unusual about that, except this
is a user operated level crossing.
And they are fairly few and far between.
This little red and green light here tells you when it's safe
to cross and then when it is you have to get out
of the car that you drove up here in, and you have to
physically pump the barriers to get them to rise.
I'm aware quite how dodgy this movement looks.
And this in itself is not too unusual, you know,
there are crossings like this in odd regional parts of England,
in the valleys of Wales, on smaller lines, but the thing
you might not know is that this is not a provincial line
This is a high speed rail line that has Javelin trains on the London to Ramsgate run.
The ones that do 140mph.
And, okay, they're not doing 140 here,
they're doing about 40, maybe 50mph at most,
but all that's stopping me from blocking this line,
or worse, being hit by something on this line, is -- well -- this crossing
and this little lever down here, that drops
the barriers and makes it safe for the trains
to cross again. That is a user operated level crossing
and that is something you might not have known.
[Subtitles: GC
Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]